we're getting our dipping pants on and
going condiment crazy in today's food
news
[Applause]
what is that ross we gotta do some wrist
exercises i know my upper body strength
so yahoo life reports that our
collective undying love for condiments
has everything to do with our memories
and the emotions that we attach to these
sauces experts say behind every
condiment you obsess over there's
probably a fond memory or association
now rossi we have a flight of condiments
here take one and tell me what comes to
mind first well i will say i love a
condiment
wellington my fiance calls me sauce
matthews because i always have a dipping
sauce around and that's right all right
and so this is barbecue ketchup yellow
mustard a hot sauce a honey mustard oh
that's underrated um
i'm i just had barbecue and you know
where i'm taken back to
when i was growing up there was a
restaurant called skippers oh i know
skippers right fish and chips and things
like that and they they had like hush
puppies and tater tots and all of it but
they had this this bar where you would
go up with these little plastic or paper
ones like this you know and i was always
in charge of the sausage so my mom and
dad would be like okay rossi you go do
it and i would get cocktail sauce and
barbecue sauce and ranch and ketchup and
i was so in charge you know what i mean
it was like the one time i had power and
everyone was getting a sauce that day
and that brings me right back to that i
love that i will say that this
particular barbecue sauce tastes just
like mcdonald's it it what
anyone lauren what sauce is this oh
you're crazy this is big baby raised
barbecue soup
i'm so sorry
um sweet baby rays ooh can i see him um
oh okay yeah thanks joey
this is so good amazing
[Applause]
from me
this is amazing
[Music]